all right Angelina
Angelina where are you from where'd you
grow up
um I like to just say I'm from South
Jersey because
um I moved in a lot of different cities
so South Jersey it's like 15 minutes
from Philly so okay and tell me about
your family
so
um I have a twin brother and three other
sisters
um
my mom and dad they met in high school
high school sweethearts kind of
um
they had my older sister in 99
me and my twin in 0-1
um
growing up early childhood memories
really all I it's all it's all chaotic
really
um just a lot of chaotic memories
um
where do I begin
yeah so unfortunately my both of my
parents they were using drugs while they
had us
um so that caused a lot of issues in my
house my father he um he is an alcoholic
and a drug addict so that combination is
just even worse
um
so
we can start with Elementary School
um
I don't really remember much about it
just because like I said I was moving
around too much
um
so
I want to say
um I think it was so it was when I was
eight so third grade
um
so I'm sorry I'm just trying to it's
hard to talk about it yeah yeah
um
so yeah we'll just start we'll just
start with the big thing
um
this is kind of how I timeline my life
based off of my trauma so when I was
eight years old I started being molested
by my father
um
yeah it was it was a lot because at the
time I didn't know my mom she didn't
really talk to us about like sexual
education she didn't teach me anything
about like what you know what was on my
body
um so I didn't really know what was
happening at the time
um
so
the abuse would happen
um mainly at night I I would be really I
would be woken up out of my sleep half
asleep
um
I
yeah I just I remember being woken up
and I am on my my dad's shoulders so
like he was carrying me like from my bed
down downstairs
um
yeah so
I remember can we can we go into it all
sure okay
um
uh yeah I mean there was times where
um like that time I said he grabbed me
on like he put me on his shoulder it
took me downstairs
um
I remember him placing me like on the
floor and I remember him telling me to
take my underwear off
and
he kind of like put me he put me onto
his lap and
it's it's really hard to remember
because you know I did go through
um you know the whole criminal that
process and everything and
um they couldn't they couldn't convict
him with anything because I don't
remember if there was any penetration
involved
so these memories that I'm sharing with
you they're more so just like images you
know flashes because I was really young
eight years old you know I don't
remember much from that time so
but
um these have stuck with me they really
have
um like I said I remember being taken
from my bed
um
there was a time
when
um I don't know where my mom was I can't
remember these times where my mom was
like I try to think back and I really
just can't but I was in her in my dad's
room and I was sitting on the bed
watching TV and then my dad comes in
and um
he he asked me something along the lines
of
can I can I do it and I didn't I had no
idea what he's talking about but you
know I kind of got like a nervous kind
of feeling so
I was just like no no no no no
um because I didn't know what he was
asking for but I just didn't feel right
so I said no and then
um I tried to get away from that room to
go into the kitchen
um I think I wanted a snack or something
and he follows me in there I remember
this and he's continuously asking me the
same question over and over again can I
do it can I do it say no I go back into
the room
he follows me in the room once again
this time he comes sits on the bed next
to me and he starts poking me like in my
stomach like over and over and over and
over again can I do it can I do it
please let me let me do it
and like to this day I don't like people
touching me on my sides because it just
it it brings me back to that
um
but
so that was an instance that I
remembered
um
see you know I wanted to go through
therapy so I can remember more details
yeah
it's it's really crazy what your brain
does to hide you know and cope with the
trauma you've been through
um your sister went through it as well
yeah
um
so let me give you the story some more
so
um so Middle School it was kind of it
felt rushed to me because I was dealing
with um that trauma and also besides the
sexual abuse
um you know it was constantly fighting
in the house my mom and dad screaming
all of the time
throwing things and it was all just
really like I said it was chaotic so
Middle School kind of just flew by for
me
um
so
when I was 12
um my mom and dad
I remember one day I woke up and um
my dad he was causing all this commotion
commotion and I go out there to see
what's going on and um he's packing all
his things so
I
you know I'm trying to listen on in on
them and see what what's going on and
um my dad apparently he had met this new
woman and he was he was just leaving
just just to go go and live with her and
it was just crazy to me because you know
he know he didn't me and my siblings you
know we were all living together with
him and my mom and literally the day of
that he moves he tells us okay bye I'm
going with some other random woman and
that's it so
I remember that day though it was a
fight my mom she I know they just wanted
to protect us we were kids and you know
we don't need to know about all the
other you know stuff going on but
um my mom I remember she was really
upset about it and she was trying to get
in his way to to block him from leaving
and um
it was just it was yelling back and
forth and I think
um
I think this there was a few incidences
where he um my dad put his hands on my
mom
um and I think I think to get past her
he had to do something like that because
she was crying
hysterically after he left and you know
it was just it was a lot so so yeah so
um
so he goes and lives with that woman and
so now we start high school
um
during the summer between Middle School
to leading up to when I started High
School
um you know we were meeting his new
girlfriend and we were getting to know
her and she had kids as well so we made
it work
um
at the same time when my mom left him
um she got her own apartment and so we
would go over there all the time but
primarily when during that summer we
transferred over and started living with
my my dad and his his girlfriend at that
time
um permanently for high school so
um
during that summer
we were going over my mom's house and my
dad would be coming over there and
we didn't think anything of it like we
thought
um you know he just wanted to check in
on us and you know talk to her chat it
up a little bit
um
but that wasn't what was going on my dad
was coming over to you know have sexual
relations with my mom and later we found
out
um that my mom she had gotten pregnant
with twins
from my dad and it's like how do you put
your kids through that whole situation
up and leave to go be with some random
woman and then you cheat on her
with our mom like
it was just so confusing and it was it
really it really just having to go
through all that trauma of you know that
whole fight initially and having to deal
come to terms with okay Mom and Dad
aren't going to be together no more so
you have to you know you have to
compromise and um
yeah it was just it was really confusing
um
it was really confusing but
I
with me going back to my trauma I didn't
know what had happened and I didn't tell
anybody what had happened
um
so I kind of just swept it under the rug
how long did it go on
um from when I was 8 to 11 years old so
um it wasn't I don't remember it being
like every single night like I said the
memories are kind of just like flashes
of like different incidents
but
um
but it was periodically from when I was
eight years old to 11 years old
um
and so freshman year
um it was all right like I said it kind
of just flew by I was adjusting to
having to live go back and forth between
two different places
um
yeah and so
10th grade comes along this is 2017.
um
same thing uh that year in school was
pretty much just um just fly by like for
me I feel like
I'm undiagnosed but I think I have ADHD
because I just feel like
I I don't know I tend to I feel like I'm
not really living in the moment and I'm
more so focusing on like too much I'm
worried about everything else and if
everything else is okay and you know
what's going to go on tomorrow so I
don't I don't know
what that is but um
so 10th grade that was whatever summer
of
that year
um
uh yeah so two days before my little
sister's birthday
um July 2nd
we had a graduation party for
um
one of my stepmom's sons and um
I remember
um
I remember being woken up out of my
sleep and
you know like when you're half asleep
and if there's like somebody around you
you can't make out what they're saying
but you just like kind of start to hear
the noise
um so you know I heard a noise at first
and it woke me up so I sat there for a
minute and I'm like okay let me see and
so I clearly could hear
um my little sister
um she was crying and she was like
whimpering and crying and I immediately
ran to turn on our bedroom light
and I see my dad run up out of her bed
and leave our room and as soon as I saw
him do that
um
I think everything hit me like because I
didn't process what had happened to me
even though I knew some like as I got
older into high school I knew something
had happened to me but I didn't I
couldn't I didn't have a name for it I
didn't know what had happened so
I think once I saw him leave things
started to click and then um
so I he immediately runs out of the door
and
um
I I asked my little sister I said you
know what just happened and she's
hysterical she tells me that
um
he was he came he crawled into her bed
behind her and he was trying to remove
her underwear he was trying to pull down
her underwear and
she was she told me she was trying to
hold them up and
and he
he was telling her to be quiet
and then she cried some more and then
that's when I woke up
and
yeah that was I think
that experience really awoke something
in me
um
I think I started to realize the abuse
that was going around I'm going that
happened to me
um
and so with that um
I just remember that night I had
I told because we've had separate beds
like it was across from each other so
she was in her bed and I told I brought
her into my bed
um and I I just remember I had
um
on my phone
I was I I had her I was cuddling with
her trying to you know calm her down and
get her to go back to sleep and
um
I remember on my phone I had 9-1-1 there
on the the keypad ready to go and I was
really contemplating it because
um
you know I wish somebody you know knew
something was going on when that
happened to me and um
I didn't do it and I think today that's
one of my biggest regrets is not calling
the police
um
when I saw him come out of the bed
because
I don't know what could have happened
um
I didn't call them because at the time
my mom she was really heavy on drugs
like I said she was living in her own
apartment but she was really she
couldn't she wasn't fit to take care of
us so
um
so you know I was like well what if they
put us into foster care because growing
up um I do have experience with that we
had to be placed in into a foster home
it was actually wild they I don't know
why they did this but they put us into a
home where everybody there they only
spoke Spanish and we were there for like
a month a little over a month and I'm
just I don't know how we got through it
but thank God I was there with my
siblings but
oh yeah it was just
that yeah that experience that that
really that started turning the wheels
in my head and
um
yeah then I started you know to be more
aware and um
I I don't know what would have happened
if I called the police
but
yeah that was
you were held at that time I was 16 and
my little sister was 11. so
um
yeah that was
that was that
after that happened
um again I didn't tell anybody I didn't
want to tell his um his wife because I
thought she would you know go to the
police or something
so
um
you know it was it was all kind of just
like it was weird it was a bad time that
night and um
after that my dad he didn't bring it up
he didn't he didn't say anything like
that the next morning I think um
he told us what he was making for dinner
or he told us what yeah what he was
doing for he was making crabs or
something and he like because I we all
really like crabs and seafood so he was
like Hey I'm I'm doing that tonight
how's that sound and I'm just like
are you kidding me like do you know what
I just saw you do last night like
so
so that happened
um
and again I I just pushed that I brushed
it under the rug just like what happened
to me um before that and
I think I was on
um I was on Auto in high school I I
really it was just it was mediocre for
me I you know I I tend to have I had
little friend groups that I was bouncing
from nothing permanent I didn't have
like one single best friend
um
I don't know I feel like I feel if it
wasn't for my twin brother I feel like I
would have had a really really hard time
elementary school middle school and high
school me and him we just we stuck
together you know what I'm saying did
you feel like what happened with your
father was affecting your life at that
time
when I was in high school like when we
were in high school yeah yeah I mean
I didn't know it at the time but you
know I started developing like really
bad anxiety and even now I'm I'm not on
any medication or anything and
I think definitely in high school I
started developing the anxiety
um
I was finally able to put the word to it
um I don't like the word molestation I
don't know it's kind of it's weird to me
but that's what happened I was molested
um
and so
I started doing my research
you know about different things on that
and I started educating myself because
my mother hadn't so I was able to learn
exactly you know not exactly because
like I said I can't remember certain
things about it but
um for the most part I was able to pick
up pick up on what happened and um
so high school
at that time it was so I was living with
my dad still and his wife and um
I don't know I think I really believe
that you can't heal an environment that
hurts you
um
just because I think I was so blindsided
I was just blind to what was going on
around I knew I knew I wasn't living in
the best situation I knew my father
wasn't a good man your mom wasn't of any
help yeah she was just in her own little
world
um
yeah it was just it was still continuing
from when my dad was with my mom the
yelling the screaming the throwing same
thing when he got with his new wife and
it just it really wasn't good and then
he had a daughter with with his wife
yeah yeah when uh that summer and his
wife didn't find out she found out yeah
she found out
um it was it was just
it was a lot I think we were all
in a way because she know she's been
through her own stuff and
he's got he's got a way over people I
don't know why but he
like you can't help but feel bad for him
sometimes I know I say that because he's
my dad but
my you know I feel like even his family
like
you know they they would say the same
things like yeah he's you know he's an
alcoholic I'll throw things but um you
know that's just how he is he's fine
he's cool you know everybody would come
over for like the barbecues on the
weekend and stuff and
you know after that we would have to go
back to
you know the darker side of it but um
so after after high school I graduated
in 2019
um
that's when I got my first boyfriend
um in high school
I didn't want nothing to do with nobody
I was like I I don't know I yeah I
didn't even have my first kiss until I
was 18 or 19. so
um everything was new to me I didn't
have experience with anything
the only experience I had with
relationships was seeing my mom and dad
and how they treated each other
and
um
so there was a situation that had
happened
um when I was 18 I got into a fight with
my dad over something and I had enough I
was just like you know what I don't want
to be here I think it's time for me to
try to move on and so my boyfriend at
that time we were looking for places and
um
yeah we we got a place together and I
moved out of my dad's house
and started living with him
um
that relationship it was it was much
needed
but I feel like it was unnecessary in a
way because
um
it was it was great in the beginning I
had met this guy at work and
um
it was great you know he was sweet
talking me saying all the right crap and
I fell for it
and so we moved in with you know we
moved in with each other
um
and then I think I think it was three
months into our relationship there was a
time when I I was visiting him before he
um
before I had to go to work and I dropped
him off at his house and then
um I drove to work and
um
I remember he had left his phone in my
cup holder and I didn't notice it until
I arrived at work
and um ladies do not check your man's
phone please if you want peace just do
not check your man's phone
um I didn't even know his passcode I was
like maybe it's his birthday and I got
it right I got it right I opened the
text messages up the first thing I see
is some girl
the top of his phone you know asking him
when's the next time he's going to see
her or something like that and I just
remember like my heart dropped oh I was
so gutted and I had to go to work then
and I'm I I remember I went in and I
don't know what I told them but I was
like listen I'm sorry I gotta leave like
something just happened I gotta go I'm
sorry
but I could not do it I like I I can't
go like oh I don't know it was just that
that was crazy to me and I just remember
it was crazy because
when he left his phone in my car
that trip
that was the same day he told me he
loved me the first time he told me he
loved me
and I and then I find that and I'm I'm
just like are you kidding me so I was
really tempted I was tempted to throw
his phone on the highway and you know
never talk to him again and just go home
but I was you know whatever so I went to
his house I dropped his phone off and
um
I kind of just gave him this look and he
knew something was wrong he didn't say
anything and I I just left and um
went home but then
um
I think I was really upset about that
for a few like a week or so and then
somehow someway
he roped me back in and you know I was
able to
forgive him I guess and um
be with him still and I just got a
product of
have you dealt with your dad yes yes
um
it's just I I used to beat myself up
over it because I remember being a child
and you know watching my dad and my mom
get in these fights and you know I would
hear you know whatever story was that he
cheated on her or he did whatever and um
I always told myself I would I would
always say you know like if you know my
boyfriend cheated on me you you I you're
not going to see him back with me
there's no way no way in how I would be
back with him you know
and um
I think watching my mom tolerate so much
abuse for my dad definitely definitely
um
kind of subconsciously programmed into
my brain that you know it's okay to
tolerate
certain things for men so that had
happened I took him back we moved out
got an apartment together I don't know
what I was thinking but I just wanted to
be away from that environment I was in
and
honestly once once I did move out I
that's really really when the gear
started turning in my head and I was
like
fully able to process like
that that man's he's he's not a good man
like there's something wrong with him
he's clearly a pedophile
and
something
needs to happen soon because like I said
he also had a daughter with
um his new wife so
for the first
few years up until 2000
last year I think it was last year that
yeah the beginning of last year I
reconnected
um so when I moved out of my dad's house
I stopped talking to him and his wife
um this is kind of jumping back but I
forgot to add this like going in like
growing up in the house with my dad and
his new wife like I told you my mom she
was you know heavy on the drugs so it
was hard you know to be to interact
with her and get much help from her so
in her place I feel like my stepmom
I I owe her a lot she she really filled
in that motherly kind of role
she um she knew structure
she taught us how to do chores she um
you know helped us get jobs when we were
16.
she I feel like without her I don't know
where we would have ended up and that's
what I'm saying like that's why I don't
sometimes
it kind of scares me you know what would
have happened if I did call the police
because we could have ended up somewhere
way worse
um
but still it is it was pretty bad but um
she was a help in all of this
um
and so I reconnected with her
like I said last year and um
so I reconnected with her because
you know it doesn't sit right with me
you know knowing what I know now
piecing all the pieces that you know
needed to come together and
um
I started kind of just like dropping
hints to her that something wasn't right
with him I didn't at first I didn't tell
her like flat out what had happened I
kind of just like I forget what I said
but something along the lines of like
he's no good or something like that and
um
these times I would do that she she
wouldn't really ask too many questions
but then there was this one time
um
so a few months ago we'll bring it up to
now because our relationship we we
really just like you know we'll check in
on each other text
um I'll visit her
um
and all that but um I reconnected with
her a few months ago
or no I not a few months ago I told you
I reconnected with her last year
um
and so a few months ago I was talking to
her again and I was texting her and I
was like I said the same thing you know
like
it's not okay
he's not yeah I
I don't know how I worded it I was
trying to be like I was trying to say it
without saying it but she she
um
she she said like tell me like flat out
what what had happened so
I told her what happened that night with
my little sister and
um immediately she
she was she was going she was going
crazy she didn't know how to react I
mean how do you react when you know
somebody tells you that you know your
partner is a pedophile or you know that
they tried to molest their daughter like
that's that's very I you know
somebody told me about that like told me
that I just wouldn't know how to react
so you know she she was she was really
Shook at first but um as she calmed down
you know the next few days she's talking
to me she's supporting with me and um
she tells me that she's she she also
suffered um
some type of child abuse she suffered
some sexual child abuse and um she
confided in that to me and you know we
became even more closer these last few
months and
so I asked her if she would come with me
to go report my dad I I have been before
I did this a few months ago I from when
I moved out
something in my soul I just I wanted so
badly to tell somebody else
and um I knew it was time to try to
report him before anything else could
happen so
she came with me to the police station
if she didn't come with me I would have
never went
um so I really thank her for that and
yeah like I said
um unfortunately because you know the
cops they need those details those
really important details I can't
remember you know fully what happened so
they said listen you don't have any
proof so there's really nothing we can
do I'm sorry and that was pretty much it
so
um
and because of what happened to my
little sister happened at a different
house I have to go and handle that at a
whole that whole County so it's that's a
whole different thing
um it's nothing ever came of it not of
my situation no but I'm hoping that
something will be for my little sister
because I don't I don't want to give up
I I think it's how do you how do you
have two daughters telling telling you
that their father
he molested me and he tried to molest
her how are you hearing that and you're
not
there's nothing that can be done about
it I just it's hard for me to understand
so
um
going through that whole process it was
a lot because
um
you know like I told you I didn't talk
to anybody I haven't been to a therapist
um
the at that time it was my stepmom that
I told it to and then I started that
process and having to talk about it is
extremely hard I remember walking into
the police station I was like so shaky
and but I do remember as soon as that
was over I talked to the detective I did
feel a lot better I I felt a lot of
weight lifted off of my shoulders
um
but
that's when because this is this is
still pretty recent that's what this was
in May that that happened
um or was it it was April May
um the end of April into May and
um
I feel like this has also kind of
created a little bit more
um like mental health issues for me I'm
not gonna lie how does it affect you
today yeah
um
I feel like it makes it makes living
hard for me
um
because I have a full-time job
um I try to go to the gym as much as I
can throughout the week and I do have
hobbies so
um
for me
that's why I was saying I think I have
ADHD because I I tend to take on so much
and
and then I I forget things
um
it's definitely I do I do ask I ask
you know I'm I'm a spiritual person but
you know God whoever you got you believe
in
um I ask why why I was born with the
parents that I was born with
um
you know I just why did I have to suffer
that abuse and then have to witness it
almost happening again to my little
sister
and you know I'm only 21 so I'm I'm just
I'm freshly an adult I'm still I'm
navigating life and
it's just
having to have a full-time job and you
know paying I pay my bills I take care
of my responsibilities but it just gets
to a point where it feels so
overwhelming
that some days I just
I feel so defeated and
um
it's a lot I mean I I cry a lot but I'm
not ashamed of it I think crying helps a
lot
um
I was watching this video the other day
about childhood trauma and how it
affects us and somebody in the comments
said
um
you know babies from birth they cry to
heal
um themselves in their trauma and it can
only it can only help if they're being
nurtured by those around them
for example like
um you know you're you're young like
three or four you're crying because you
know you couldn't get you know the
cookie you wanted and your and you know
your mom's screaming at you no like stop
crying like you're not getting that blah
blah blah and it it subconscious
subconsciously it makes you think you
know showing your emotion and you know
expressing how you feel isn't okay and I
think that's in a way that's kind of
what I did I saw the people around me in
my environment you know take on the
abuse they were taking on whether that
be mentally verbally physically whatever
and kind of just sweep it under the rugs
so
like I said growing up through middle
school high school I just I really just
somehow my brain just
really just put it back there and I
didn't touch it again until after I
moved out
and so um yeah I love crying but it's
annoying though it is also annoying
because you know
but it seems like going through that you
carry it with especially because it
isn't really resolved your dad is still
out free right yeah yeah
seems like it
kind of
dissipates your ability to focus or do
anything in life yeah for sure um
so I I do have a partner now and
he's he's been by my side while I'm
going through this this process and with
the new detectives and all that and he
was telling me like
you know it's it's not going to give you
any healing you should you should just
you know he'll get his karma and you
know he'll get taken care of one day and
you know I agree with him I shouldn't
overexert myself I've been through
enough with him and
I should just let you know the universe
take care of him but also deep down
it's it's just it it urges my soul
because if I know there's something I
can do I'm gonna try to do it and that's
also um
yeah I tried that you know I took it
upon myself to go and Report what had
happened to me and um
if your father was exposed would that
put your mind more at peace
I mean I don't think so just because he
is kind of already exposed now I
shared that um I had made my story
public
um
and I had posted it on
on like Facebook or you know something
for I just wanted like if he's not in
prison he's not in prison no so you know
I mean posting about it definitely did
help me in a way yes I think I think he
he should be exposed
um
but I also
I don't think that
I don't think his life can get lower
than it already is now because like I
told you he is going through divorce
um
you know his house their house is under
foreclosure
um
he doesn't my other siblings they don't
talk to him
he's still on drugs and he's still an
alcoholic and
um
it's just the same old stuff so we all
kind of just like let him be
and so
um
that's fine but like I said
me personally I don't I don't think
I didn't think that it was right to keep
in what I knew when he had he had
another daughter and she was she's she's
two years away from the age that I was
when he started molesting me so
I feel like deep down in my soul it was
urging me to speak up about this now and
confide in my stepmom and so that's what
I did yeah and um
she's going through the divorce with him
um she doesn't really she's done with
that
um
but it's gonna it's gonna be hard you
know because I don't know how
the custody is going to work with
their daughter and you know
I don't know but I do have people around
me that are helping me with the process
and
um
my support system now is great
um therapy would probably be great what
is it therapy would probably be great
for you yes I
so
have health insurance so the state of
New Jersey
um
there's programs you can sign up for and
they offer victims of abuse you know
free mental health services so
I I had called like three different
times and I even had an intake
appointment once and they said okay
we'll get back to you a couple weeks and
we'll assign you with your therapist I
didn't hear from nobody and it's been
months so
it's just like it boggles my mind like
I understand these people are backed up
but you'd think there'd be
quicker
quicker ways to provide help for the
victims because unfortunately some
people they can't take it anymore and
they do
you know
um
they have to leave but um I'm hoping to
be in therapy soon yeah I am
um
I would say
for me art is one of my biggest outlets
for me I started taking art seriously
when I was uh in ninth grade I started
drawing
um and then I started painting really I
love doing portraits drawings all that
stuff and then um I turned it into
tattooing so these tattoos I have here
I did these all myself and I'm hoping to
be a tattoo artist eventually so I want
to be in my own shop and you know just
prove you know my family wrong because
outside my immediate family the rest of
them you know it's
it's hard a lot of them also come from
you know the drugs and alcohol and it's
a lot of abuse going on so I'm just
hoping that I can make something
different out of it and be successful
one day but um
yeah that would be great yeah
Angelina thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you thank you you're
still young you have lots of years
thank you